we were just kids when the bombs dropped  and the world went to [ __ ] they said it  was supposed to be the end of everything  but for us it was just the beginning  [Applause]  surviving nah we were better than that  this new world had a lot to give and we  took it all that's how we came out on  top that's how we got here  that's how we found you  listen here rabbits you need to  understand something the only currency  left in this world is power we're gonna  take everything from you starting with  your home and if we can't take you  we'll break  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I led us into the new world I thought  that it would be glorious I was wrong  [Music]  you  you